[Musique]
tu dors ton moulin va trop vite
je suis ma guele roseau la Jérôme des
moulins de Rambouillet le samedi 6 sur
le site de La Bergerie Nationale
implanté depuis maintenant 6 mois nous
sommes prestataire de service pour La
Bergerie Nationale ainsi que les
agriculteurs locaux qui souhaitent
transformée lors céréales sans farine
actuellement la farine de La Bergerie
Nationale qui est une farine de type
T110 ou tu es 150 farine semi-complète
ou complètes destiné aux particuliers
ainsi que son fils ou boulanger on vous
emmène découvrir aujourd'hui la mouture
de la farine de des céréales bio de la
bergerie
[Musique]
la première étape fait le remplissage
des silos donc à la fin des moissons aux
alentours de la mi-août par La Bergerie
Nationale intérieur là nous avons du blé
qui est bio sont les cultures
biologique de La Bergerie Nationale
de nettoyage du grain c'est nous qui
avons choisi de
faire cette cette étape elle n'est pas
obligatoire elle permet de retirer la
poussière et les petits et les insectes
qui peuvent encore se trouver dans les
céréales
[Musique]
on se retrouve du coup après le brossage
donc on a une machine qui est ici et qui
nous permet de monter le grain jusque
dans le moulin c'est un moulin de
fabrication française il est monté sur
mail de Pierre c'est du granit et des
sur de melon a une meuf qui s'appelle la
meule dormante et on a juste une bulle
tournante en haut et descend de la
Tréminou parce qu'une fois sous les
meubles pour ensuite suivre le circuit
je fais l'écartement des meules si les
mots ne sont pas serré ou écartés
correctement on va se retrouver avec du
trop de gras à la sortie alors que le
but c'est de récupérer toute la farine
de n'avoir que du son à la sortie de la
famille 2
le brassard ici on peut offrir ici donc
là on se retrouve avec la farine qu'on
peut appeler intégrale c'est-à-dire qu'à
la farine et également le son qui n'est
pas encore séparé on a un cheminement et
on arrive ensuite dans la tamiseuse et
donc ensuite ça coule ici donc là on a
juste la farine
et on a le sang qui sort à la fin
silence hachage
faisant penser à acheter des sacs de 500
g jusqu'à environ 6 kg
et la toute dernière étape c'est la
couture
quels sont les étagères pour notre
producteur 1er donc La Bergerie
Nationale donc voilà on peut retrouver
une gamme de 1 kg de 5 kg
et ensuite 25 kg pour les boulangers on
produit pour la bergerie environ 45
entre 40 et 45 tonnes de farine par an
[Musique]